Sie haben einen Schauplatz, geben Sie irgendwelche bewegenden
Verstöße, nein, Sie trinken bei der Arbeit,
Sie haben jemals jemanden bei einer Arbeit geschlagen
Ihre Ausgangssperre und
es ist ein Pferdefonds, den Frank Sheeran macht, ist
ein besserer Fan davon, kämpft gegen diesen Klick
und Google, sie sind in der italienischen
Mafia und arbeiten zusammen,
um uns auseinander zu ziehen,
etwas muss getan werden, was er sonst noch
sagt, jetzt ist nicht die Zeit, es nicht zu sagen
Sie sind die weichsten Waffen, eine andere ist die
Anglosphäre, innere Hormone oder etwas zum
Säen und Immitis. Ich bin Frank Sheeran, ein System, das
ich für die Kunst entworfen habe. Es wird DeNiro
sagen, und es sagte, und Dan, komm schnell zu uns
zu
verkaufen und wie ich weiß, ist der Schritt fest
nur ein gefrorener ergonomischer auf ina
und was Moussaka und Mythos am höchsten auf
einem anderen bei anderen Freiern sind Ophelia
wunderbar aufregend und ich habe
Dustin nie gegen noia einen
Ärger ayodhya zerschmettert  Unterhalten Sie mich, er kann
Martin Scorsese nicht absaugen, dass Sie
meinen Cousin Russell Bufalino kennenlernen
schlussfolgern
Izar Magnetron und Danby's in Ziffern
kommen durch eine Artikelarena und Omaha,
aber in Amerika auf einem Feinschmecker zu Sir Master
Jimmy Hoffa,
aber im Winter wieder hatten sie jemals die Begeisterung
von Florida Teamsters Metallzinken
Casa Sprenkel noch bei politischer Natasha -
Taktik hier auf dem Tisch  Designer Ayats
Video für unsere Umgangsidee Mafia als
McGann's Kansas wirklich schwierig, wenn
Sie die hier waren, die für unseren Pitino verwiesen wurden.
Damals gab es hierzulande niemanden
, der nicht wusste, wer Jimmy
Hoffa immer mit einem Typen
mit einer Waffe belastete  Messer, du rennst weg, also wirst du
mit einer Waffe aufgeladen,
was für ein netter du bist ein Opportunist, Waffen
werden nie eingegriffen Alpha-Team DeNiro
Tzu bin in einem Berater  s Günstling Ich
weiß, dass die Gerichte dort
Organisation für Fragen sind, um
Millionen von Menschenhandel zu bringen, weil
sie in Schisma gefangen sind, um dem Omni eine natürlich politische Falle zu stellen,
weil er
auf Schnatz und einen Klempner ein
Theater macht, der dort Ihren Tod tut
Mafia-Aliens zwingt die Vieira-Flüssigkeit,
jemand in Goodfellas ist nicht die Zeit
, in der wir ihre zukünftigen Wege auf Olivenöl haben
, und all das Unitas ist hier
Dunkelheit, ja, er ist eine Tanzplatte, nicht auf
psychischer Gültigkeitsmechanik für ma, ich meine, so eine
Familie von ihnen in der Tat  Freiheit Afyon wurde
gesehen, besuchte, mischte sich ein,
mischte sich ein, wurde dort fest gefeuert. Ich meine, es war, du weißt, dass
es war, aber
ich mag es nicht, in der Hamas verrückt zu werden,
du weißt, ich verstehe nicht, was du getan hast oder
nicht
, das macht keinen Unterschied für mich, ja, ich
weiß  Ich bin hier, um dich zu verteidigen,
richtig, richtig, was willst du, ich weiß nicht
, ob ich das getan habe
[Musik]